على الاختيار بين تمويل حربه الوحشيه او
دعم اقتصاده المتعثر بهذه العبارات وصفت
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه اتفاق الحد
الاقصى لسعر النفط الروسي اتفاق اتخذته
مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا
ويدخل حيز التنفيذ اعتبارا من الخامس من
فبراير ويستهدف حظر مشتقات الوقود الروسيه
مثل البنزين بانواعه والديزال المنقوله
بحرا ويحدد الاتفاق سقفا لسعر هذه
المشتقات الاغلى ثمنا عند 100 دولار مقابل
السقف للمنتجات الاقل جوده مثل زيت الوقود
عند 45 دولار خطوه هي الاحدث في اطار مساع
غربي لاستهداف صادرات موسكو الرئيسيه
هذه العقوبات ستقود اقتصاد روسيا
السقف المحدد حاليا على اسعار النفط
الروسي يكلف موسكو حوالي 160 مليون يورو
هذا الحظر الثاني جاء بعد فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي في ديسمبر حذرا على الخام الروسي
الذي يصل بحرا وحدد سقفا عند الستين دولار
للبرميل على الصادرات حول العالم بعد هذه
العقوبات الغربيه تراجعت ايرادات النفط
الروسيه في يناير ادنى مستوى لها منذ عام
2020 بحسب بيانات وزاره الماليه الروسيه